displaying how Jamie's roll will look
like in the last six episodes of Game of
Thrones so without further ado let's
just jump into it in the end of season
seven Jamie finally sees Cersei for what
she really is an insane delusional and
power-hungry queen who will betray
anyone to secure her reign no matter if
her own life or the whole realm is in
danger Jamie finally abandoned his
sister he now writes not to support the
living side he is no longer in the
Lannister uniform he's no longer
commanding nori presenting his house
Jaime is dressed like a cell sword the
first scene we will see of Jaime in
season 8 will be at the crossroads in a
popular stop for travelers on Kings Road
Jaime will stop at the inn for the night
this is also the place Jaime will
reunite with Bronn
the next morning Jaime and Bronn will
ride West the crossroads signalized the
meeting point of major roads which run
north-south and east-west the Kings Road
runs north to Winterfell and south to
King's Landing the river road runs fast
into the Riverlands so where Jaime and
Bronn riding West to the Riverlands
instead of North Winterfell as Jaime
announced he will in the season 7 finale
that something Jaime will explain to
bran were having a pleasant meal adine
basically before going to Winterfell
Jaime firstly go to the Riverlands to
gather as much forces as possible since
the living side needs every soldier in
the war that is coming Jaime will take
the command of the Lannister soldiers
that are located in the Riverlands
remember that part of the Lannister army
has been sent there to ensure peace
there's been some trouble rise up of the
twins so we thought the army has been
sent to keep the peace upon getting the
Leinster forces jimin will then write a
river on to try to come inside
militarily to let his Tolley army to
Winterfell and help his nieces and
nephews defend it in the second episode
Jamie will arrive at Winterfell will be
brown by his side and the Lancer forces
that he managed to gather Jaime will
have a huge reunion with quite a bit of
characters Tyrion Imbrium would be proud
that Jamie has honored his pledge while
the nurse will be a little bit
suspicious about his intentions of
course the most important reunion is the
one between Jaime in the Starks bran
Stark in particular as we all know back
in the first season Jaime was caught
having an intimate relationship by brain
to keep bran from reporting what he had
just seen which whatever zalta the Jaime
Cersei and all her children being
executed Jaime had to push bran out of
the tower window causing brandy ability
to walk and rendering him a [ __ ] the
only question regarding this reunion is
how will brain react at first glance or
assume that bran will react angrily
since thus the man who almost killed him
the last time they saw each other but
that will most likely not be the case in
fourth episode of the seventh season
brinster stated that he is not brain
stark anymore but rather the three-eyed
Raven meaning that he will not sentence
Jamie to death nor will he love John
ordinary so do the same
rather than sentencing Jamie to death
bran will reveal to everyone the real
truth behind Jamie's so-called betrayal
over Daenerys is fired the Mad King in
the third episode of the season Jamie
will participate in a huge battle for
Winterfell this major battle sequence
was already filmed it included around
500 extras and it left Winterfell sad
burned down there are photos in which
you can see hundreds of farmed extras
fighting in the battle some of those men
are the unsullied buildings Pearce
tipped with dragonglass meaning they are
fighting against the army of the Dead
even though the living side will suffer
a tremendous defeat at Winterfell most
of main characters who make it out alive
including Jaime Lannister the entire
living side will have to seek refuge
summer south and as it's been confirmed
by leaked photos jon engineers who come
to King's Landing to once again parley
with Cersei in the end of season seven
search his plan was to allow her enemies
to exhaust themselves against the army
of the Dead then had the golden company
mop up the remnants of whoever's left in
the north however the army of the Dead
is the one that will win the battle for
the north this is a moment sir sill
forge a new plan she will now allow the
entire living side to seek refuge at the
capital but she will also open the city
gates for the army of the Dead surcease
plan is to have all of them fighting
inside King's Landing
whereupon she would burn them all with
wildfire that is hidden all over the
capital and that FEI get rid of all her
enemies
these seats in which Cersei has a pearl
in King's Landing with Jon Snow is most
definitely taking place in episode 4 due
to a fact that director of episode 4 was
spotted during the filming so he have
Sir Civitan escort her Queen's Guard
including Gregor the mountain Clegane
having an important meeting with unarmed
Jon Snow the Lannister flag flow above
the fortress indicating that Cersei
Lannister is still in control of King's
Landing at first glance it will seem
like John is coming to plead for Circe's
help after the living side has suffered
a huge losses at Winterfell after all
John would not return to enemy territory
unless the circumstances were dire
however John is coming to Cersei to
propose her two options to either accept
the entire living site of sick sanctuary
in King's Landing now that the night
king and his army have successfully
gotten past Winterfell or to refuse and
get herself burned down by either denge
dragon or even by the night king's
dragon as she will not be able to stop
him by herself long story short this
huge meeting between Cersei and Jon will
end with another fake promise on sources
behalf she will ensure Jon that the
living side can seek refuge in gangs
Landing and it must
fall while she's actually setting
already mentioned trap having in mind
that the person John has come to parley
with is Cersei Lannister many fans are
wondering if Cersei will have John
captured even though she would most
certainly like to do that she will not
be able to capture and execute John like
she did not Stark or at least not at
this point of the season
the reason being Daenerys Targaryen
presence it's not only John who came to
part of it Cersei he's accompanied with
Dany one leaked photo shows a figure
silhouetted in an archway the figures
seem to be the nearest herself as the
figure has blonde hair or dark outfit
and the chain across their front it
looks the same to what the nurse was
wearing last season Cersei will not be
able to capture John or even both John
and the nearest for the matter because
of Dana's dragons how do I know the
Danish dragons will be flying about the
capital during this meeting well beside
the nearest being there as you can see
this part is taking place in front of a
window
HBase Reichardt brilliant spoilers this
season and this was horrible way to do
it
so filming this major scene in front of
a window must have been necessary for
the scene anyways at some point the
filming crew said green screens across
that window meaning that Cersei will
have a clearer view on the new dragons
flying about King's Landing and
therefore if she is to capture and
execute any of them Cersei knows that
the entire King's Landing would burn
down however even though Cersei will not
be able to capture Jon nor Daenerys in
episode 4
she will capture Jon in episode 5 Jon
just like Eddard Stark dead back in the
first season will do something honorable
that will get him captured without
anyone knowing Jon will go to the red
cape to have a word in private with
Cersei basically John will just like
netid weren't Cersei to flee into exile
and step away from the Arryn Toronto
avoid her certain death but also to save
her an unborn child however this will
result with Jon being captured and
locked up in dungeons the nurse will not
be able to do anything because if her
dragons start to burn down the red keep
Johnson would burn down as well anyways
ruthless as she is her still make one
mistake that will cost her life Cersei
will have Jaime to meet her in the
throne room just before she intends to
blow up most of King's Landing Cersei
still of Jaime doesn't want him to die
so she was summoned him to meet her and
dead face save his life
this face Cersei will assure that only
her enemies would burn down while her
and Jaime would be the only ones left
however this is a huge mistake on
Circe's behalf as Jaime will not only
prevent her from burning down the
Capitol but will also kill her one scree
page from episode 5 involves Jaime
trying to convince her see that her
chewy enemy is the night king rather
than Jon Snow and therefore she should
release him from the dungeons he says
Daenerys is not your enemy
snow is not your enemy the only enemies
you have to worry about are outside the
city gates right now
sir she takes her seat at the throne
saying nothing Jaime inches closer to
his sister his face is contorted in a
look of desperate leading disgust to
work Jamie says sir see you are your
intelligent woman you may be jealous you
may be cruel but you know how to place
your bets
keeping the only man who can defeat the
White Walkers in Chains is not a smart
bet sir sir responds with you would help
me release the usurper tell me after
that northern fool and his white-haired
defeat the night king what do you think
will happen to me Jaime answers you can
defeat the night king on your own on
which search the replies with can't I
Jaime pauses racking his brain what this
could mean and then it hits him Jaime
the nest Cersei if she's referring on
wildfire
Cersei nuts Jaime asks are you sure we
have enough catapults on it Circe
responds with vivan be using catapults a
long measured moment of silence here
Jaime looks at Qyburn dentist Circe he
shuts his eyes his worst fears have been
confirmed this is a moment Jaime
realizes that his sister and former
lover is no different than a Mad King he
had to sacrifice his honor for and say
many innocent lives
Jaime realizes that Circe intends to use
wildfire to get rid of all her enemies
including Johnson Dana's armies that
came to save the capital Jaime realizes
that search is about ordered the entire
city to be burned down to ashes with
million of people in it rather than
support the link side and fight a knight
King because she knows the dueling site
is to win she will not be able to keep
the Iron Throne jim starts walking up
the steps to the throne the mountain
watches him closely breathing heavily
from under his own Jaime says you can't
do this Cersei there must be another way
Cersei replies there is another way the
city gates will fall in an hour
Jaime that says innocent lives are at
stake here 1 million innocent lives
Cersei fidgets in her throne
uncomfortable and says to her brother
get away from me unfortunately we don't
have a following page at the moment but
we can also what is going to happen next
Jaime already sacrificed his honor once
in order to save hundreds of thousands
of innocent lives by killing the Mad
King and has ever since been called the
Kingslayer however Cersei now intends to
do the same it's pretty safe to say that
Jaime is going to kill his sister when
she gives an order to Qyburn to as the
Mad King used to say burn them all Jaime
will do noble sacrifice once again but
this time he will not trade it with his
honor this time it requires his life
Jaime would sacrifice himself by killing
Cersei as he knows the mountain will
kill him immediately
Jaime will kill the ruler of the Seven
Kingdoms once again but this time people
will not mark his name this time
everyone
we'll know that Jamie Lannister is the
savior of the city and the only reason
they're alive his name will be
remembered as a hero in this great deed
will fulfill his empty pages in the
famous book of brothers so this is the
famous book of brothers all the great
deeds of all the great Kingsguard Arthur
Dayne the sword of the morning that the
attack on the Kingswood Brotherhood
defeated the smiling knight in single
combat
so don't conduct or four pages for sir
Duncan he must have been quite a man so
they say mr. Jaime Lannister someone
forgot to write down all your great
deeds best tool time is there for a
forty-year-old night with one hand so
Jaime Lannister knighted and named to
the Kingsguard in his 16th year at the
sack of King's Landing murdered his King
Aerys ii pardoned by Robert Baratheon
thereafter known as the Kingslayer it's
the duty of the Lord commands to fill
those pages and there's still room left
in mine in the leaked script it also
says that the fountain Brianna writing
towards red keep at a moment of Jamie's
huge argument with Cersei therefore it's
safe to say that the Hound viiiains help
element Jamie's death she will arrive in
the throne room at the Hound just at the
time to see the mountains writing down
Jaime the Hound will then finally fight
his brother while Jamie's exhaling his
final breath in Bryans arms dare he have
guys detail Jamie's fate in the final
season Jaime Lannister might not be the
one to save the link side from the night
king but he will be the one to save them
from the met Queen Cersei Lannister